okay so I did beat this guy with one H5
last time so I think I should go one
H4 B6 on B6 I think E4 is a decent
response and
uh yeah VIP counts as Subs that's why
just I could comment okay that makes
sense yeah so this like in the
corresponding line with reversed colors
I
think um the the thing is like there's
some F5 line and then the queen is
coming to H5 but or in this case H4 but
with a Pawn on H4 that is not that is
not a problem think I could go E5 now
also Bishop sorry Bishop H G2 fails to
Rook H2 which is Bry and foresight I
would
say
um this looks bad takes takes Queen
G4 and once again I mean Bishop G6 runs
into
H5 this one H 1 H4 move is just
brilliant like every single line here
after B6 E4 I would guess after B6 E4
white is probably a bit better or at
least not even close to be
worse
so I think he chose like the only
reasonable move where H4 is actually
very
good so maybe you
know this guy is actually not the op
Aran that everybody thought he was maybe
Arian is the op
Arian okay let's
capture G5 I
think so now my plan was to
take
um take on E7 and then start harassing
his
Bishop is that a good
FL if I go start harassing it
immediately he might
take no if he takes then I
can then I can take on C2
okay
should be good then because I was
thinking takes HG and then he can park
the bishop on
G G6 but I just take his other
bishop and now I think I take
H7 KN of
three like if you could develop really
easily here I mean he still has Bishop
B4 which I
missed so he's sort of getting a game
but I should be much better with the
extra pawn and
potential big pass Pawn okay so he goes
for
um Queen deployment
Instead This should be
insufficient
yeah I kind of want to want to keep
playing playing for the initiative here
with
D6 because it was certainly possible to
drop the queen back to E4 cover the
diagonal
and then just keep going from there but
I
thought let's try and win in the
attack
I am I mean his King is a bit Airy and
I'm not even material
down so I should be doing
brights this looks
[Music]
wrong about Rook
D1 yeah I'm getting Knight D4
now I got a couple of options like the
fanciest is to go Knight
D5 oh no then he can trade and ask King
okay I'm going to keep it simple Bishop
H4 then Knight D5 also Bishop C5 I go
B4
I'm sure I have many good moves here but
when in doubt you know
centralized so Queen E4 this should be
should be
curtains now Knight D6 is just resides
in the spot yeah poor
aarin he's had a he's had a t time
against me today uh